aquí en Moscú la policía ya ha tomado
posiciones de Cara a las manifestaciones
que están convocadas para el día de hoy
no solo en la capital sino también en
hasta 30 ciudades rusas Aunque la
Organización de las marchas se ha visto
complicada por las redadas policiales en
algunos de los colectivos pacifistas que
estaban detrás de estas protestas desde
el gobierno se recuerda a los
manifestantes que se trata de marchas no
autorizadas además se ha endurecido la
legislación Y a partir de ahora el
acudir a este tipo de actos
reivindicativos se va a considerar como
un acto más de desacreditación del
ejército Por lo cual se puede penar
hasta con 15 años de cárcel la mera
presencia en una de estas
manifestaciones los rusos han pasado de
La indiferencia a la preocupación sobre
la llamada a filas por eso siguen
formándose largas colas de vehículos en
algunas de las fronteras terrestres de
Rusia apenas
billetes de avión para los próximos días
y todo el mundo espera con temor las
noticias de sus parientes o amigos o
familiares que pueden recibir en
cualquier momento la citación para ir al
frente